please welcome Quentin Tarantino
thank you
welcome mr. Tarantino please take right
here uh welcome to Hall H good to be
here nice to see you
you seem pretty chill and relaxed
considering what you're standing on the
precipice of showing footage before that
no one's ever seen Tommy I'm really
excited by it because you know actually
was funny because up uh the company made
the movie The Weinstein Company put
together a trailer and I kind of looked
at it and like well it's not quite right
because it's looked almost too early to
make a trailer for a film I go wait a
minute now but much of people are coming
to Hall age to see me announce my new
movie then they're probably already fans
so they don't really need to see a
Pacific Rim sizzle reel right so I
decided to cut together a special me my
editor who spent two days this week and
we cut together a special seven-minute
piece just for you guys
and so I'm I'm pretty chill cuz I'm just
really waiting to see you guys response
to what it is that we did I mean I think
I think one of the reasons why I mean
obviously the movies are great but you
also being you're sort of a character in
the meta part of the movie too because
people just like if you go to the New
Beverly or you see how clearly intense
you are about making it the lenses are
right like you love this this is like if
one of you guys just started making
movies like that's that's basically what
you get to do oh yeah and I mean well if
people keep asking me about a senator
comic-con and I remember you know the
days that I used to come here like in 88
and 89 and 90 where is like July was
like the most important time of the year
I basically made $10,000 a year from my
minimum-wage job and you would just save
all year long for July so you could come
down here and you and five guys would
rent a room together and stay so you can
submit another night here and like just
spend my money on bootleg videos and
vintage movie posters and action figures
and all kinds of cool stuff light lunch
boxes Man From UNCLE lunchboxes through
the artwork by Jack Davis on it it was
awesome and have you have you been
enjoying that watching the growth of
comic-con
yeah no very much so I mean some people
complain about it and everything but the
idea about like oh it's not about comic
books anymore that's BS I actually came
here two years ago I wore him
a so no one knew who I was and I
actually filled in all these holes in my
comic book collection it is I usually I
wear a Lucha Libre mask but that's a
yeah it if you see blue demon walking
around might be me it's fun there's so
many people it's hot and fun and sweaty
it's the only place you have to wash
your hands before you go to the bathroom
but it doesn't matter like it's a good
time but is a but being able to when you
you basically went antique shopping to
find these lenses oh yeah so what how
did you guys decide well this is the way
we have to do it this this ultra rare
ultra old way to present this movie well
it was just the fact that um the fact
that like you know we were first just
looking for a really cool scope 70 min
later lenses but when we found these
ones and it's like the biggest format
available to seven six you know so
normal scope is two three five this is
two seven six so it's literally is the
biggest format available other than some
360 thing that they have a you know
Grand Canyon stuff at Disneyland and um
uh and I remember the movie shot in this
you know these lenses are actually it's
not they use the same type of lenses on
Ben Hur they used these lenses on Ben
Hur oh they these lenses only they only
made one set of them they only exist as
this group so these are the lenses that
made Ben Hur these are the lenses that
they shot it's a mad mad mad mad world
in they shot the Battle of the Bulge in
the the Marlon Brando mutiny on the
bounty these are the same lenses they
use so this is tremendous how are you
not like can you hand me that oh [ __ ]
like how do you not I mean you're
basically guarding history yeah a little
but you're it's but it's working history
yeah no I'm well actually our you know
question was because you know we were
shooting in such frigid cold area
environment it's so you know that like
normal cameras just freeze and stuff
normal lenses freeze all the time and so
I was running like how are these gonna
work out there in that cold but the
camera department just did a fantastic
job of just putting test after test
after test and putting him under the
right conditions keeping them warm we
never had a situation where they stopped
working and we couldn't work that day
they never had a situation where they
froze you know it was really I had such
a
make camera Department I don't know if I
would have the balls to actually have
done the film without a camera
department that I could so truly trust
yeah pulling this off yeah and do you
feel like it yeah the foot camera
Department not all directors come out
here and give props to other people that
work for them they just take the
accolades themselves so that's very kind
of you but do you why was it important
for you to tell this particular story
this way and did it was that when you
first envisioned the movie were like we
want to shoot it as wide as possible or
that just evolved well you know it it's
sort of kind of evolved as time went on
I mean the the the initial idea is like
I'm I am NOT a fan of digital projection
I mean I everyone knows that I'm not a
fan of shooting on digital but I'm
definitely I'm not even a fan of digital
projection by losing film projection to
me we've already seceded too much ground
to the barbarians and and so the thing
about it is my feeling is okay look I
didn't work 20 years to work to uh
diminishing returns and so just the idea
of shooting my movie and we have a
couple of screenings in 35 and then just
arrest our DCPS
that's not why I got into this business
that's not the movie industry I signed
up for and so I thought well if I shoot
it in 70 they're going to have to
release it in 70 or else they wouldn't
waste that money so that was the initial
idea all right was saying well if we do
it in 70 then I will guarantee
definitely some film a quite a few film
screenings around the world even though
I know that this is gonna still be
playing in mostly 3,000 theaters in
digital um but then what happened is
once we got these lenses and we started
putting it together then it all kind of
really kept evolving one of the things
people say to me all the time they go
yeah but you know we've heard that most
of the film takes place in one area like
Reservoir Dogs right alright so what's
the point of shooting 70 millimeter for
that and I'm really looking forward to
the film kind of my movie breaking that
notion because there is this sort of
notion that basically seventy millimeter
is for travelogues basically it's to
shoot Lawrence of Arabia it's all about
desert landscapes or mountain mountain
scapes and then that's why people would
shoot 70 millimeter know when you shoot
a big 70 millimeter
like that and you shoot it indoors it
can actually be more intimate it can
actually take you closer to the actors
again make everything more vivid and
more vital so it's not just for shooting
travelogues it's not just for shooting
beautiful sceneries it's for shooting
great drama well I think that is an
excellent place maybe we should show
these people some of the things that
you're talking about right now so this
show you guys ready to meet some of the
hateful eight never-before-seen footage
cut specifically for Hall H roll the
footage hateful eight please welcome to
the stage mr. Kurt Russell also Jennifer
Jason Leigh Walton Goggins
deme Beshear mr. Tim Roth Michael Lanza
and mr. Brewster
welcome everyone welcome ah good to be
here
it's good - fantastic welcome hey Kurt
Russell hello how's it going good
uh sick mustache really rad always on
point um so how did you how did you get
involved basically - Quinn just call you
and say I want to do a thing and you
said well do whatever you want or did
you had it had it to come to pass I was
last year
yeah and Quentin called and he said I'm
gonna do a reading of this script would
you you know you want to take a part of
him and I said sure I'd be great and he
wanted to rehearse it so a couple of
days in the rehearsal I found out that
we were gonna actually be doing it in
front of a crowd about this size yeah we
were stood and then after we did it it
was it was quite a fun experience and it
it played really well and Quentin
decided he wanted to make the movie and
I was just thrilled to be having the
opportunity to be a part of it
how is it different working with I mean
if it feels like I'm assuming from an
outsider's perspective is probably a
unique experience working with well I
could get myself into a lot of trouble
here there's nobody like this guy yeah
it's in the league of his own and I
think all you guys know that I think
he's just shy yeah it's gonna be hard to
sit next that we could go on and on and
on but I it's honestly true that every
couple of generations or so somebody
comes along who does it not only
differently but does it his or her way
in such a way that its inimitable when
you see five frames of anything he does
you know who's doing it and I really
mean this sincerely and I think all the
all great actors that are sitting here
would agree I would wish this for every
actor actress that they have the
opportunity to work with Quentin once
it's a it's a fantastic experience not
just in terms of what he does but it's
really more how he does it it's a circus
that you want to be a part of well we
have about 20 minutes so I want to make
sure that we get as many fan questions
as possible so that you guys can can
drive this and have all your questions
answered so let's shine the light light
well hello amazing
I like your tailor young lady hi what's
your name my name's Alyssa Camacho well
hello what is your question my question
is for mr. Tarantino and it is if you
are going to use this same style of
anime from Kill Bill volume 1 into the
hateful eight somehow no there's not an
anime sequence in the hateful eight uh
where were you when I needed you that's
probably a pretty good idea I'm thinking
about some of the flashbacks could have
been really good in Japanese anime that
would be cool no we're not doing it on
this one but I'm very flattered and
gratified that you're such a fan of that
you look amazing
she just cartwheels out hey what is your
name
I'm Joey by the way she's probably the
coolest parents in the world
ah yeah my I wanted to ask or they're
dead we don't know we don't know maybe
she we don't know oh I don't know my
question was for Quentin as it was
reported the original script for this
was leaked online and until I heard that
you by the way until I heard that you
were rewriting it totally then I read it
and it was great um my question was did
the arm did the fact that you had
already had a story for this make it
difficult to do a total rewrite and also
second question sorry about that what
would be seeing the bride again in
perhaps in volume 3 uh yeah so the thing
about it was um what what pissed me off
about what happened with the leak was
the fact that normally I kind of finish
a script and once I'm done with it I'm
ready to go into production but this was
one I kind of wanted to go through three
drafts I wanted to get there I didn't
want to like have to uh you know like
there's certain plot threads that were
in the first draft that I I wasn't quite
ready to tie up yet but I knew I had a
couple of drafts to go so um so that's
why I was a little distance
when it got out there having said that
though you know the my process was my
process so even though I yelled and
screamed about it I kind of kept on
doing what I plan to do so it you know
the second draft and the third draft is
what I ended up shooting and was where I
was going anyway with it so that kind of
just went on the way it would it just
got more public than I wanted it to get
and um uh we'll see I never say never
we'll see all right you know uh when it
comes to Kill Bill 3 would really like
to do it we talk about it every once in
a while or so alright uh we've got we've
got to wait for vanitas daughter to get
old enough to go and kill her so uh
we'll see
I have a question just as we're sort of
weaving these in for Jennifer Jason
Leigh is there anything that you can
sort of tell us about the essence of who
your character is because obviously we
got some glimpses without giving too
much away what can you say ah well she's
being taken to be hanged by this man and
um she's doing everything she can to
survive she's a bit feral uh crazy like
a fox I would say she's yes she's pretty
smart excellent and I was very excited
to see Walton Goggins and I were in
house 1000 corpses together and you are
in a Quentin Tarantino movie now and I'm
very excited and proud for you this is I
said I'm just excited that you're just
seeing where we all kind of started out
and now you're way huge I mean like had
it what was it like for you coming onto
the set with all this pantheon of actors
I mean yeah look around you know really
it was uh it was extraordinary there's
one one scene particular I mean I can't
really go into too much but there was an
opportunity to kind of interface with
almost everyone up here and and and and
it was at one point during the rehearsal
period with Quentin I just stopped and
and you're just kind of a filled with
this emotion because it's like you you
hope that you can hang on long enough to
put yourself in a situation where a
filmmaker like when you know gives you a
shot and and then you look around at all
of this talent I mean I remember where I
was when I first saw every single actor
up here and it's just it's been an
extraordinary run managed it's really a
specialist specialist you're a very
special boy Walton Goggins I'll I'm a
specialist
what what is your name sir hi my name's
Sam my questions for Quentin Tarantino
I was just wondering since you just made
Django Unchained and you're making hay
palade are you a Western director now
can we expect more westerns in the
future yeah I actually uh I actually
feel that when it comes to westerns uh
maybe not in the old days when people
made 20 westerns or 25 westerns as well
as doing other things but I think at
least nowadays you have to make at least
three westerns to call yourself a
Western director and or anything else
you're just dabbling in the genre and so
uh III will eventually make three
Western so I can officially call myself
a Western director throw my westerns on
the table with all the other Western
directors and then we'll just see how
they stand excellent good question I'd
love to hear from Damien
too well just anything about your
experience on the film and just the
elements of it and it seemed very
claustrophobic in parts of it so what
was it like yeah it was it was all that
you know when you become an actor this
is what you want you want to work with
the best directors and uh and fantastic
cast and so for me I mean I've been a
big fan of all these guys for many years
and I can only say that I had the best
seat on the house watching all these
guys in action that that was my gift
yeah you know I don't want to say one
thing about Damien it was really
interesting because uh uh when I in the
very first draft of the script uh Bob
was a Frenchman all right and then I
decided in the second draft that changed
into a Mexican and then but I couldn't
think of anybody immediately nobody came
to my mind immediately to play the
character and so I should I called up my
buddy Robert Rodriguez and I go okay so
like I'm writing this Mexican character
and everything who would you recommend
from the different Mexican actors that
you know would you recommend somebody in
particular he hadn't read the script or
anything and he goes up Oh Quentin
Demian Bichir Demian Bichir that's who
it is
we did machete kills together and you
were fantastic in machete kills because
we didn't machete kills together and
through the whole movie I kept saying
you're a Quentin actor quick got luck
with you
you are a Quentin actor all right and so
he just said it's Damien just don't
don't talk about it just hire him
I love your rubber hey what is your name
hi my name is Jose um Quentin you just
answer my question because I'm also
Mexican Damien Lau Ching Gong tower oh
so you fuh Michael yeah why do you cast
the man I mean you can also cast you
said a French and also German what you
didn't care Chrissa Waltz is your
favorite I I think but um why do you lie
eh what do you like about the man no
well the thing about what the thing
about it was well Jamie is just an
amazing actor and actually to tell you
the truth it's like of all the
characters if you look at what's on the
page and then you see what Damien
delivered with it it's like the one like
how the [ __ ] he get there from here
I mean what's on the page doesn't really
reflect what he ended up doing am I
wrong about that it doesn't reflect it
at all
all right he's like the page [ __ ] the
page he just moved on his own playing
and we're all the better for it
uh-uh you're talking about a true
chameleon here we worked together for
four months all all of us right when we
got on the plane from Los Angeles to
come down here
none of us recognized Daniel we know he
was with so he's gonna miss Jennifer's
security nobody knew he was a Tim Roth
was the same was the same experience for
you and sorta developing that this guy
like how did you get how did you arrive
at this particular character I just did
what he told me to do which is pretty
much what you have to do I mean there
are very few directors away writer
directors will you read it and it and
it's done you it's very very clear um
from what's on the page what you need to
do and there isn't really an
improvisation necessary it's it's
incredible experience so I just did but
the main concern really was am i doing
it too much here
Oh to over top and conquer no no give me
more yeah to Tim's performance is a
little bit a gallery of great British
character actors from the past uh give
me a little Terry Thomas on this one yes
all right so when you so when you and
Michael Madsen and you guys get together
is it does it feel does it feel new or
does it feel like oh is just was where
we just we just left off here we're just
we just picked up where we left off
before I get that like I think we picked
up where we left off but I I think it
went one step farther I think we are
even better we're smarter a little bit
older but still under control the best
director on the planet that's one hello
sir what is your name
uh my name is Drew and what's your
question
drew stop first off I love you uh what I
do drew oh uh I just wanted to ask
recently interview said that you were
probably or you most likely could stop
after ten films and I wanted to how much
validity there was to that and if so why
no well you know what we'll see what
ends up happening and that was more that
wasn't so much a mission statement more
that me trying to have a serious
discussion of an artist vitality in
public in a world where that's not
really a good thing to do yeah you know
in a world before they was all broken
down into like a 133 articles where the
paragraphs are taken out of context
all right um but there is an aspect of
you know I do kind of like the idea of
10 and done there is kind of a koala
there's a kind of neat thing about that
I do like that we'll see what happens
but you have to keep in mind though um
if I go by that my normal route of the
last 20 years I usually make about three
movies a decade so this is like number
two for this decade so even if I were to
end in 10 that's still like another
decade and a little bit more to finish
that up
however if things change as far as like
you know if I can't shoot on film if I
can't release to some degree or another
on film I don't overall I'll even make
10
however the thing we'll see what happens
all right and I might just say the hell
with that and make 15 who knows but I'm
uh but I do like the idea of getting out
leaving you a little bit leaving you
wanting a little bit more I like the
idea of getting out while it's like I'm
Lea was so good I don't want to be out
of touch and you know and if everything
changes well then I guess I am at a
touch it's time for me to step aside and
let other people take the road um on the
other hand though part of the thing I
don't like about digital projection and
all that to me it's just HBO in public
we're just watching television in public
so if that's becomes what movies become
then I can move to television alright
you know then we'll cut out the
middleman and then you know it's like so
maybe there's ten movies and maybe I
have three miniseries in my future where
then I could like just write my stories
and there as long as they are and I just
shoot it all and then these little
novels for television and that's all
good yeah sounds good that people seem
happy with that I mean my scripts are
always too long to get in the hole
except for Kill Bill all my scripts get
cut down anyway so if I could actually
just write a story and it ends up being
eight hours and all good oh good
or it just goes on forever yeah in five
years you have to shoot it on snapchat
like there won't even be one of these
anymore
the guy is an emoji movie uh what is
your name sir hey how you doing Oh
Martin how's it going hey mine this is
kind of a daunting panel of coolness so
I have a little trouble here
so I'll direct this to Kurt Russell
you've played some fairly recognizable
characters over the years uh snake Wyatt
Earp
Jack you know as people that maybe
recognize how'd you pull those
particular characters in to give some
spirit to the character that you play in
this movie this coming up you're
actually very insightful and how I go
about my work um I think one of the fun
things you can do as an actor and I kind
of figured out when I was for me anyway
when I was 27 or 20 27 years old had the
opportunity to play all this Presley
nobody else really wanted to do it I
figured well [ __ ] it if we're gonna do
this I'll go down in flames that's a
good one to go down with
and that didn't turn out that way and
for this for the first time I got to do
something really the way I wanted to do
it and I got it to do with a man named
John Carpenter who we then went on to
make partner and he gave me the
opportunity to do things you know kind
of the way we both saw them the way I
wanted to do them and I always wanted to
try to have the chance to create people
that I were to me you know hopefully
something that people could watch and go
that's a little different I guess guys a
little different than that I know
somebody kind of like that so I have a
tendency to take people from my real
life or people from the movie business
take little pieces of them there's six
very specific people who are John Ruth
they are there they are my my guiding
way to find John Ruth and it all comes
from what he wrote and discussions with
Quentin it was an interesting this one
was an interesting one I didn't I didn't
get this right away I didn't yeah I was
struggling a little bit
Quentin was helping me kind of try to
find a way whatever it is is what it's
going to be but that's a really
insightful question for for me thank you
very much oh well done mr. bruce dern
love to hear from you for a sec Bruce
how do you fit in to all of this how do
you fit into the story who is this guy
Bueller ah I fit into the story I think
because the kid grew up watching me be a
jerk on television and there there's
like a couple of things I'll say even
though it's not directly an answer to
your question the excitement for all of
us was just to be asked by this man to
be in his movie that's number one number
two he has Quentin has the greatest
attention to detail
on a set making a scene as any director
who ever lived if he had a rival it
would only be Luchino Visconti secondly
he creates an atmosphere for all of us
not to do our greatest work necessarily
but to get better and he does that for
everybody on the set
not just the actors but everybody else
and I was excited to come to work every
single day with this man because I
thought we just might have a chance to
do something that's never been done
that's Quentin Tarantino that is uh
that's a that's a climactic beautiful we
have time for one more question
no oh you come how can you do that to
her don't be evil let this poor girl ask
a question or I won't really be able to
do anything about it
otherwise I guess turn her mic on uh-huh
okay let me show you repeat it back you
could have my mic her name is Natalie oh
okay there we go
no yeah go go go we forced them into
submission go ahead um first of all I
just want to say Quinton you're so
awesome my entire family loves you
oh thanks Ryan and my question is what
is your favorite thing you've ever said
or written in a movie oh that's a good
one
oh wow that is a good one actually last
question good last and you were gonna
let her to it you monsters oh gosh uh uh
god that's actually such a good question
I don't really know if I have an answer
for especially with this press for time
bill shake all right uh uh uh you know
uh gosh darn
um you know I can't fit right right now
I can't think of anything as far as a
writer is concerned alright that I've
written that was like my number one
favorite no I take that back
alright yeah my favorite thing I think
I've ever written is uh the scene in the
French farmhouse at the beginning of
inglourious basterds before that it was
in my very first script true romance it
was the whole Sicilian speech and I
always know that that was the one to
beat and then when I finally wrote that
scene in Inglourious Basterds like oh I
think I finally beat that one excellent
well you guys uh please go well I'm like
one announcement to you guys that people
don't know yet so I'm gonna announce it
out here now is it wasn't for sure and
we just kind of settled it down you guys
know that I normally don't use an
original score in my movies I kind of
take scores from other movies and put
them in there and this one I kind of
thought maybe this should have an
original score and so I'm here to
announce that the great Eno Morricone
whoa well not only be doing an original
score for the hateful eight that he's
writing right now will be will be a
recording in Prague in the next couple
of weeks but that will be his first
Western score in 40 years
fantastic I think we should all go to
Fri hateful eight comes out December
25th of this year Christmas Day please a
huge hand for Quentin Tarantino in the
cast of hateful eight thanks for coming
guys
I really appreciate it
senior Christmas
you